hey youtubers is Charlie and hopefully
you've all had a chance to see the
Walking Dead finale I just did a QA and
tried to answer as many big questions
about that as possible so now we need to
talk about season 5 because they are
already releasing news so what I'm gonna
do is start with the really big news and
then do my top 10 predictions based on
that also a lot of you have been asking
me what kind of Walking Dead videos I'm
gonna be doing during the off season
since we're transitioning into Game of
Thrones I'm probably going to step it
down to about 1 Walking Dead video week
at least 3 per month be sure to leave me
suggestions for what you want to see in
those in the comments below but be sure
to subscribe to get everything because
dragons are coming this week and it is
going to be awesome
so the really big news right now is that
Gareth Terra and Rosita have all been up
to series regular for season 5 this
tells us one that those characters
probably aren't gonna die anytime soon
and it means that they might be spending
more time at terminus than expected as
in multiple episodes I'll talk more
about that during predictions but let's
try to answer this really big question
first if Rosita is now a series regular
then why didn't a brand Eugene get
promoted to series regular just means
that you'll be in more episodes get more
lines and obviously you get paid a lot
more I think what's happening is is that
Abraham and Eugene will be taking a road
trip without Rosita and that'll just
occur off-screen for the most part now
that so many of the survivors are back
together they'll ply just spend most of
the first half of the season at least at
terminus specifically which actually
leads me to predictions so careful for
potential spoilers from the show or the
comics if you're not cut up or you don't
want to know anything but number 10
Abraham and Eugene will bolt from the
group and head for Alexandria during my
Q&A I talked about cannibals eating the
biggest people first and clearly Abraham
and Eugene would be at the top of their
list at least after Tyreese but their
characters just have way too much story
left in the comics even if the show
remixes everything that's supposed to
come next they'd still be a part of it
but because they're not serious regulars
like Rosita now having their story
literally you know travel off-screen
would be a good way to start throwing to
Alexandria Abraham's whole mission has
been to get eugene to Washington DC
and he's got that stubborn military
mindset and he's not gonna quit until
complices that goal so obviously at some
point they're going to have to separate
and take off speaking of separate number
nine
Carol Tyreese and Judith are still going
to be on the road in season five there
was that lingering shot of powdered milk
outside the train car that made everyone
wonder if it was being used to feed baby
Judith but after staring at it a third
and a fourth time I think that it's just
what they were using to feed the
survivors that we saw you know Glenn and
Maggie's group Scott Gimple said
something really vague on talking dead
about them being out there somewhere we
already know that Beth's story is going
to diverge just a little bit from the
survivors for most of the season and
it's also possible that Carol Tyreese
and Judith could sidestep terminus
altogether they've already confirmed
that there will be more action in season
five and wouldn't having a baby right
there in the middle of it kill all that
tension Rick would do a complete 180
back to farmer Rick so I think they
won't appear at terminus at least not
while [ __ ] is going down between the
survivors and the cannibals as much as I
would love to see Judith reunited with
Rick and Carl her not being there just
spares her from being turned into a
hamburger number eight the first half of
the season will definitely be a terminus
Gareth is a series regular now there
would not be a reason to make him one if
the survivors were just gonna blow right
through on their way to Alexandria so
them escaping and defeating the
cannibals is just gonna cross over
several episodes which i think is great
they teased so much mythology in the
five reel minutes we saw of terminus
we'll get to learn all about that creepy
religion they practice what the candles
are for and the history of terminus they
wrote that creepy mantra all over the
wall for a reason
clearly the Savior's or someone really
bad came there at some point and took
advantage of them so this isn't a
prediction but wouldn't it be crazy if
the Savior's at some point in the past
came to terminus took all their food and
that's why the people there turned into
cannibals just because they needed to
eat and there was nothing to eat negan
in effect made them cannibals made them
this evil version of the prison number
seven the people at terminus are
actually a cannibalistic cult inspired
by the hunters here's where we need to
distinguish the act of eating human
flesh from what actually happens in that
weird
shrine if they were just regular
cannibals they would eat people out of
extreme necessity the people at terminus
sitting around that grill seemed like
they were very well fed meaning they
probably overeat like they eat steak
three times a day when they probably
could have just survived on a fraction
of that in order to get all that meat
they would have to be killing a lot of
extra people and if you look at the
bones on that tarp that rip runs by not
only are they remains of several people
they look fairly recent old bones would
have been way more bleached and there
wouldn't have been any blood left on
them by the way brick definitely took a
long look and saw that they were human
bones even if he didn't say anything
about it
the real mystery in my mind isn't so
much that they're eating people it's
what is the ritual involved with that
act I'm wondering if they're worshiping
something ethereal like the virus or if
they're praying to an actual God I'm
really looking forward to rick trapping
gareth in a classic evil guy monologue
where he explains their whole plan does
anyone remember that awesome incredible
syndrome line you caught me monologuing
number six terminus has no single big
bad but mary played by Denise Crosby in
Gareth our co-leaders on a council
Gareth is definitely not a big bad like
the governor but he does have authority
and from the way everyone treated Denise
Crosby it looked like she's like the
evil Hershel of their group I sense a
nice dichotomy between the prison and
terminus as in terminus is just an evil
universe version of the prison start
trying to find out who everyone's evil
twin is if it were Star Trek it'd be
easy and they'd all have beards speaking
of which let's talk about Denise Crosby
they wouldn't have cast someone like her
in a throwaway role I think it's just
more evidence that terminus is rule by
Council I'd call them the Legion of Doom
but that's really what I think the
Savior's are gonna be number five one of
the survivors has probably accidentally
already eaten some people meet a lot of
people actually thought the voice is
coming from those other containers were
Beth Carol and Tyreese but they sounded
just a little too different to actually
be them I think they're gonna be some
redshirt characters that Rick and the
survivors will watch get sacrificed in
Episode one terminus is threatening
because of all those guns so they need
to witness someone actually getting
eaten
to become horrifying who else noticed
how many times rick and michonne talked
about being hungry and how there's just
absolutely no food around they have to
eat at some point and for the time being
they can only eat what the terminus
people feed them and what do they have
to give but more people meat based on
how long they've been there I feel like
at least one of those survivors in Glenn
and Maggie's group has already
accidentally taken a bite of steak
without realizing what it was I'd say
Abraham is probably the most likely
candidate he just seems like a steak and
potatoes kind of guy number four it they
will make it to Alexandria but not till
the end of the season all Abraham has
been talking about since he appeared has
been Washington the train car they were
locked in had a giant a on it too and an
NW for Northwest we all expect them to
get there eventually but based on the
casting upgrades that included Gareth it
became pretty clear that Alexandria is
way further in the distance I really
think that's a good thing because once
they do get to Alexandria you get to the
Savior's and it's all just downhill from
there right now in the comics there's
that all-out war storyline and I think
for them to jump to that before season
six or seven it's just way too soon if
you are reading the comics then you can
take comfort and something Robert
Kirkman said recently basically it was
that all the things that you think are
coming are coming it's just the
differences is the show remixes things
so you might not get exactly what you
think you're gonna get things just won't
be exactly the way they are in the
comics the best example is the character
Gareth I personally think he's a twist
on Chris the leader of the hunters if
you are interested in reading the comic
and you want to get ready for season 5 I
would recommend reading volume 11 it's
called fear the hunters and it deals
with all things cannibalism number 3
Rick is going to say his famous line
from the comic books so rewind in the
comic books from the hunters a little
bit back to issue 24 rick has this
famous line we are The Walking Dead I
kept expecting him to say it during the
finale it just felt like every single
character was giving him an opportunity
trying to set him up for it
hopefully they'll twist it just a little
bit and turn it into something of valor
I you know he did say that line they
messed with the wrong people but I'm
holding out hope that he will say that
famous comic book line in season 5
number 2 so this is a big one
Beth's storyline in season 5 will follow
a different path from the survivors and
we won't see her as much
Robert Kirkman was fairly non-committal
about Beth's faith and he said we might
not even see her during season 5 I think
that's a bit misleading I think we will
see her at least towards the end just
not with the survivors I think it was
Jesus that took her or they'll combine
his character with father Gabriel either
way she's on her way to Alexandria even
if she doesn't get there right away
she'll still spend most of the season
apart from the terminus people remember
that foreshadowing from the finale
there's a new sheriff in town it just
implies that she'll become a little bit
more of a badass I think that's what all
those scenes with Daryl were setting up
in that moment with the spoon by the
time she is reunited with the survivors
though I think she'll be a little bit
more like Carol maybe a slightly less
hardcore version no matter how awesome
Beth gets I don't think she's going to
become the kind of person that would
kill a child and my number one
prediction we will not see negan until
well after they make it to Alexandria
based on Gareth being upgraded to cast
regular I think he's going to be around
for a long time and in a lot of episodes
meaning there really isn't room in the
narrative for negan yet him showing up
is just entirely dependent on Wednesday
arrive at Alexandria and even then it
might be another repeat of what happened
in this finale you know you get a flash
of Alexandria for like five minutes and
then you get introduced to him and
that's it and they just leave all the
character development for the following
season it's even possible that they
could push him all the way to the end of
season six but now it's your turn let me
know what are your biggest predictions
for season five you know how long are
they gonna be at terminus is gonna be
more than half the season and if best
storyline is gonna happen apart from
them is she headed to Alexandria
so my next Walking Dead bonus video will
pry post next week be sure to leave me
suggestions for what you want to see in
that in the comments I'll be shifting my
focus a little bit more to Game of
Thrones now because episode one's gonna
air on Sunday so get really excited for
that I'm probably gonna have at least
three maybe four videos for that this
week too so right now click here to get
my review the finale and click here to
get my Q&A thank you so much for
watching I'll see you tonight
high fives
you